Good afternoon, and thank you for joining this particular
session on neuroimmune
crosstalk in cancer.
These are my disclosures.
So for many of us who are very interested
in the tumor microenvironment,
you can see all the
usual suspects, the stromal cells, the cancers, the
macrophage, the neutrophils,
the T cells, and the B cells.
However,
something happened in Germany 175 years
ago.
Rudolf Wagner
found that when he stimulated the nerve
in a dog,
the spleen moved.
So he contacted his friend, Jacopo Andy,
and he said, "Can you do an experiment for me
with human data?"
So his friend
did the same thing
with a decapitated human,
something that I truly do not want any one of you
to try.
And then subsequently,
a lot of people, including Paul, could
start tracing these different nerves.
So all of a sudden, for us who are cancer biologists,
we start thinking about
what if
all that we've been doing,
looking for the metabolic adaptation
that would stimulate the immune system
to improve
immunotherapy or genomic instability,
which would also be something that we really
now know
can stimulate the immune system against cancers.
So this neuroimmune crosstalk in cancer
becomes real
because that stimulation of the nerves
that the spleen moved, perhaps what we're doing
is sending a message from
nerves into the immune cells.
And of course, there are
the central nervous system and the peripheral nervous system, and
mainly what we're going to be talking about is the peripheral immune
system. We can have the autonomic nerves,
which is splitting into the sympathetic, which makes
norepinephrine, fight and flight,
and then the parasympathetic
make acetylcholine.
But this is not really
secretable,
the acetylcholine from the T cells
to other cells and in the neurons are
mainly synapsis.
So we will talk about today, the three of us,
how these nerves actually
play in,
innovate, and crosstalk with
the tumor microenvironment.
Now, the field is slowly growing now.
As of last year,
2,000 papers have been published
on neuroimmune crosstalk.
Out of that, about a quarter of them
are now starting to ask questions with respect to what
will be involved
in the cancer setting.
Today,
we have three speakers
who are all very seasoned in this field,
and we have, as you can see here,
written some
reviews for those of you who want to get involved.
I will give the first talk,
Tumor Immune Microenvironment:
Time to Chat.
Professor Trumpp
will talk about neuronal innervation
of pancreatic cancer,
and Professor Talbot will talk about nociceptor
neurons impact
on antitumor immunity.
My journey
came in 2008.
I was at dinner at a metropolitan club in
New York,
and I met some neurosurgeons.
They told me stories which
made me
so curious that we started working together as a group.
The story was
that although
extrapolation from the German stimulating nerves,
acetylcholine was indeed found
about 100 years ago,
and that if you actually stimulate the nerves, there would be more
of this acetylcholine.
But what was curious and mysterious was that
up to todayIt has been very difficult to
find cholinergic parasympathetic nerves
within the spleen, the lymph node, thymus, and
the liver.
So the question then is,
where is the acetylcholine coming from?
As it turned out,
that these autonomic nerves
do usually hit a celiac ganglion.
In the case of parasympathetic, they hit a celiac ganglion
with acetylcholine, but then it comes out acetylcholine.
But in some of these situations,
like in the spleens and the liver, very
likely,
that the parasympathetic nerve comes in as the acetylcholine
within the celiac ganglion made a switch.
With time, you make norepinephrine.
And these are the main organs
where it had been very difficult to find
fibers of acetylcholine.
So what was easy to do- Several years ago,
what was easy to do was to actually
make
a mouse with ChatGFP,
not ChatGPT.
And that, in a way,
would be found that the CD4 cells and the CD8 cells
were making a little bit of it.
So to make a long story short, within the last
10, 15 years,
we've been looking at the idea
of how these T cells
and these B cells make acetylcholine along the way.
Norepinephrine can stimulate T and B cells to make
acetylcholine,
depending on the B cells and where they are.
The T cells
can be stimulated by norepinephrine, but T cell
receptor,
together with IL-21, is perhaps the main
stimulus.
So
why? It's because when we have
inflammation in certain part of the organ,
the message has to go back to the brain, and the brain
send back a message to exactly the same place where
there is
an inflammation
or a cancer.
And that way
it gives the immune system an extra
boost
or an extra dampening signal so that
we can control
our physiology and pathophysiology.
I just may give you an example.
The two viruses many of you are familiar, they are called
LCMV,
and the Armstrong forms an acute infection
where there are lots of short-lived CD8
effector cells.
But the clone 13, which only differs by two amino
acids
and was originally found in the brain of a patient,
has a persistent infection
where there is exhaustion
and CD4 cells get involved.
So the number of CD4 cells that make
acetylcholine
in the normal mouse is about 2%,
and CD8 cells is almost nothing.
However, if you infect it with a lymphocytic
choriomeningitis virus,
about 50% of the T cells are pumping out
acetylcholine. But what is
interesting is the acute infections will jump
from zero to very high and come straight back down to
zero,
whereas the protracted infection, the CD8 cells hang around to make
sure
it's clean, and the CD4 cells do the same thing,
but they maintain a higher
baseline.
So we say, "What are these
doing?"
So Maureen Cox
decided to delete
acetylcholine transfer from the T cells
only.
So the whole mouse has every cell that makes acetylcholine the
way it should be, but now the T cells cannot make acetylcholine.
You can see definitely does this result
reveal a genetic proof of function
for Chat in T cells viral infection.
What is the mechanism?
It did look like that in absence of
acetylcholine from the T cells,
the blood vessels are smaller and fewer,
and we suspect
that the acetylcholine, in addition to chemokines and
adhesion,
will then interact with endothelium
and then induce the muscles to dilate so
that
the T cells can go out.
And it makes sense because only those T cells
that had the T cell receptor
amplified or stimulated should be
going out.
Now,
just to kind of confirm this,
Peder Olsson and us
collaboratedTo show that in mice
that have T cells making acetylcholine,
the blood pressure is lower.
And more recently,
he was able to show that in patients with
severe circulatory failure,
those patients who do have acetylcholine
do much better than those that do not.
Perhaps have something to do
with activation, dilation, hypoxia,
whatever, we do not know.
And in mice, when induced EAE,
a form of MS,
it is these T17 cells that parries
the acetylcholine that causes the disease,
and those that do not, actually do not.
So it's become clear
that T cells,
and later I will show you the B cells,
that this acetylcholine that is being conveyed
to them
allows them to
basically function in a more proper way,
amplifying
or slowing down
certain physiological functions.
So I think this is really the beginning of an iceberg.
So
I am of the opinion
that every single cell of your body needs
these adrenergic and acetylcholine receptors at
some point, at some time.
You may not see them now,
but something happens, they will come up or they will come
down.
The basic message is,
somewhere something is happening pathophysiologically.
The message goes to the brain, comes back,
usually it's vagal nerve that hits a celiac ganglion,
then express into a sympathetic nerve,
and they
will secrete norepinephrine to activate the T cells and the B
cells together with the T cell receptors
and the B cell toll receptors.
They would then
not secrete acetylcholine, but they will then
basically make a synapse
with almost every cell of your body at the right
time, in the right place, for the right reason.
Now, this is going to take a long time to solve.
There are five muscarinic receptors, GPCRs.
There are 16 nicotinic receptors, but some
of them form heteropentamers,
making the situation so complicated that I begin to
believe there may be dozens,
if not
100 of these receptors.
And there are these nine adrenergic receptors, which are
GPCRs.
So Kai Qi in Beijing found that the alpha
nine
is actually required for the maturation of B cells
into plasma cells.
Shangfen Liu
in our laboratory did a very interesting experiment.
He found that the alpha nine is on double positive thymocytes.
A message from a T cell within the
thymus
gives
it an extra calcium signal,
which would double the number of T cells
in your body.
So this is the way the brain is saying,
as evolution progresses, we are exposed to
more viruses, more bacterias, we need more T cells,
and alpha nine provides that.
Well, how do I think that? Because when he knocked it out,
then there is less T cells
repertoire, about half. And
the T cell receptors composition
and the repertoires are different.
Such that, in fact, when given autoimmune diseases,
it is less.
Moving on to the germinal center,
where T cells and B cells were given
maybe three, four, five days to come up
with not only the best cytotoxic T cells,
but also the one with the highest affinity B
cell
antibodies to neutralize the pathogen.
That race for time
is completely controlled
by acetylcholine from the T cell telling the B cells
not to blow every single B cell, but
only the ones with the highest affinity, so
then they can become the even higher and higher and higher
within the three, four, five days that you only have
before the pathogen takes you away.
At the same time, the B cell will tell
the T cells
what to do with another acetylcholine
signal.The complications
is so immense that multiple muscarinic
receptors
switch on to nicotinic receptors during that
maturation in order that we actually do
have exactly what we need.
In my final seven minutes,
I'm going to go into the liver,
and this work done by two very talented post-doc,
Nasta Ran
and Chung Sheng.
I had always thought
that looking at sympathetic nerves in the liver,
I never thought that there was anything interesting.
By the way,
nobody had found cholinergic nerves in the liver.
But when I saw this paper by Adori et al.,
I was stunned.
You could see that every part of that sympathetic
nerves, which is red color,
has only one friend.
The friend is the portal system,
which is the portal vein, the bile duct, and hepatic artery.
What does this mean?
It means everything that comes through the portal vein
and the portal system will be soaked in
norepinephrine,
because norepinephrine has a half-life of two hours.
You cannot escape it.
To me,
it must mean that the portal system
and everything that comes through
need
norepinephrine. Otherwise, it's not going to be
physiological.
So what Nasta Ran did was to do
the partial hepatectomy,
which is very interesting. Your partial hepatectomy,
your liver decides to divide
or not divide in two to four hours,
and then it will stop on day
seven for a mouse.
So there are many, many cells that are involved.
And I'm taking the liberty of this really beautiful picture from
Pardo in Madrid,
where the hepatocytes is the princess.
This princess needs many, many other cells
that have to look after them.
The smooth muscle cells, cholangioctyes, satellite cells, et cetera.
But in there is also T cells and B cells.
Oh, and the autonomic nerves.
So what Nasta Ran did was to deprive the
mouse T cells acetylcholine, and then cut
out 70% of the liver.
Guess what?
They don't care.
But
when she deprived the mouse of B
cells making acetylcholine, the mouse dies.
That means B cells is needed for the liver
regeneration.
So
what does this say?
Without B cells making acetylcholine in the
liver after partial hepatectomy,
Cooper cells
make less IL-6.
That is the brake. That's the accelerator.
And T cells make more gamma interferon.
Without this, there's no liver hepatocyte regeneration.
And with this
high,
it will stop.
So norepinephrine, LPS, activate the
B cells to make acetylcholine, to activate the Cooper cells to make
IL-6, and now the hepatocytes can divide.
That's the accelerator.
In every case, when you drive a car, you need a brake.
The brake is acetylcholine from the B cells,
tells the CD8 T cells
to make less gamma interferon,
so the hepatocytes can divide.
What about liver cancer?
Well, with P53, p10 and MYC,
Chung Sheng started the liver cancer model.
If in this model, the T cells
cannot make acetylcholine,
you ended up with more liver mets.
The mechanism is acetylcholine
needs to keep
the T-rex down
and the PD1 down.
In its absence, T-rex goes up, PD1 goes up,
then immunosuppveillance
is compromised.
He actually was able to find some T cell
receptors
that he thinks are responsible.
But more importantly, as again,
only the T cells or mainly the T cells with the acetylcholine
are actually functional.
High fat diets, same story.
In a Western diet,
if the mouse cannot make acetylcholine in the T cells,
you get more tumors.In
human,
the different receptors go up and go down,
whether the tumor or the normal hepatocytes.
And
some are good prognosis
and some are bad prognosis.
So we're beginning to look at the complexity of this
situation.
And the complexity
is perhaps beyond our immediate, clear
understanding of a simple solution.
My final slide.
Different subtypes of breast cancer,
basal,
luminal A, luminal B, HER2, and normal,
they all have different
acetylcholine and adrenergic receptors.
And they indeed make a difference with respect
to
even prognosis.
So I think
I have 20 seconds left.
I would say, what are we going to do?
Luckily,
there are still lots of things to do.
For example,
in the gut, in the intestine,
we think even the
motility
and tumor genesis also
has an impact
when some of these
T cells or B cells not making acetylcholine.
Acetylcholine, as I said,
cannot be secreted. It's a synapse.
The only
surrogate you can use is choline,
and choline acetyl CoA
makes acetylcholine.
Now, choline, of course,
is not just for this,
also
with DNMT1,
with methionine as epigenetic changes,
but also
for phosphatidylcholine, sphingomyelin, you also need choline.
But nonetheless, these three doctors measured
choline level of patients
they treated with immunotherapy.
And this is the result.
Thank you very much.
Now we have
five
minutes for questions.
So if we are to target these cells,
put it in the system, the T cell,
would it affect these CMS
for cancer?
That's a very good question.
Because a lot of the receptors are found in multiple organs.
But their signaling is very different.
Alpha 7, for example, is a positive signal in neurons,
but it's a negative signals in myeloid cells and in T cells.
We have to be able to target these
in a very organ-specific manner,
and we're working very hard on it.
Thank you. Hi, Professor.
Sorry, I think I was first.
Okay, sure.
Thank you very much for that talk. I was really struck by the
phenotype where you showed that
T cell-derived acetylcholine had no effect on
the survival of mice after
liver injury, but the B cell-derived acetylcholine did.
From my very naive understanding, number one, it's the same acetylcholine
regardless, and two, T cells are the predominant lymphocyte
type in the liver regardless compared to B cells.
So where does this difference arise?
Is it because of proximity to the source of the acetylcholine,
or is it because of maybe an autocrine loop?
And I guess the follow-on question is, do you see other instances where
there's a difference between B and T cell-derived acetylcholine?
In every situation, the B cells and the T cell-derived
acetylcholine are different.
So we're beginning to think that there are very specific synapses with its
target cells.
That would be question number one, answer my last question.
And in respond to your first question, after partial
hepatectomy, there is a
flood of B2 cells coming in through the portal vein
system.
So even though the B cells are outnumbered by T cells,
the number of B cells making acetylcholine, both from the B1
within the liver and the B2 coming in through the portal
system,
apparently met the demand.
So in that case, that's contingent on the acetylcholine only
behaving in,
only exerting its effects through a synapse, so it's proximal.
Absolutely.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you very much. That was a very interesting talk.
I'm kind of new in this field, so I was wondering if,
do you have any suggestions as to how would be best to identify this
type of acetylcholine signaling transcriptomically, right?
Because right now we have a lot of availability with spatial transcriptomics, so if
we want to see if they're having this behavior.
But I worry that trying to see this acetylcholine activity, you
need to look at it at the mass spec level, but I don't know what your perspective
is.
Well, it's a very good question. Obviously, we cannot make a human
with GFPSo
the Per Olofsson's lab does
qPCR on the T cells from these patients, and
he thinks that the result is very reliable.
And so for the time being, that's all we can do.
Perhaps,
better technology can be used to detect
what I think is a quite crucial
neurotransmitter that has expressed on a very transient
basis.
Mm-hmm. Okay. Thank you very much.
Hi. Very nice talk. I was wondering if you wouldn't mind clarifying your very
last slide, which you showed the Kaplan-Meier,
which patients with high choline are doing much better. Is this TCGA data?
No.
It's our own patients' data.
Okay. So this is actual measurement in serum?
Yes.
Okay. Thank you.
Hi. Thank you for the talk. Regarding
the acetylcholine interactions observed in the liver,
especially since liver isn't really my area, I was just wondering
if this was observed in the nerve system
inherent to the liver, or if potentially you've looked at
neural invasion, if that's something that happens in the liver as well as in other
areas like the pancreas?
It's a very good question. I think there is specificity within the
liver content. For example, in our first
paper by Colin Riordan, he found that B
cells with Tolle and CCK in the
spleen can make acetylcholine. But in his
paper in 2013, he found that
norepinephrine cannot activate B cells to make
acetylcholine, but norepinephrine can activate T cells.
Then Nastaran more recently looked at the B
cells in the liver and
showed that norepinephrine can do it.
So I think it's quite
context-dependent where these B cells are lying or the T
cells are going.
Okay.
Got 24 seconds. And then the next speaker
is Andreas Trump.
Yeah. Thanks very much, Tak, for the introduction,
and also appreciate that you pronounced my name is Andreas
Trump with two Ps.
It's quite important these days. And I'm really
happy to be here, and thanks very much for the invitation for the
2026 AACR. So what I will do in the next
20 minutes, I will tell you about profiling and targeting innervating
peripheral neurons in pancreatic cancer.
And this is a story we have just finished, and I'll show you also some
unpublished data. And the three heroes in my
lab who actually have done this is Vera Thiel, then Simon
Renders, a clinician scientist, who also actually now starts or
runs the clinical trial, which I will summarize at the end, but we are planning
here, and Jasper Panten, who has done all the bioinformatics.
So this story started when Vera actually
updated and optimized iDISCO protocol, which is used
to actually make
tissues or organs completely transparent.
And you can read your newspaper through it, but the really
beautiful part is that you can actually still label them with
antibodies. And what she has done is used peripherin or other
antibodies to label the peripheral nervous system.
And then you can use light sheet microscopy to actually make 3D
images of the complexity which happens on the peripheral
nervous system in all the different organs of our body as well
as in cancer, which is shown here.
So as you all know, all healthy tissues, all healthy organs are
innervated by the peripheral nervous system.
The motor, sensory, autonomous components releasing
neurotransmitters and trophic signals to main our tissue
homeostasis and keep our organs functional.
So it's not surprising at all that in arising
cancer in all of those organs, actually you have a benign
disease, it grows, it actually starts to contact blood vessels,
but of course, it will also contact already preexisting
neuronal cells actually in that tumor
microenvironment. And therefore, it's clear that the
PNS becomes automatically part of the tumor
microenvironment. And that's been recognized by a
number of researchers, and
there has been as a large literature on potential interaction with
metastasis, obviously cancer
associated pain. There is a
growing field of the interaction with the immune system, as we just heard
from Tak, and inflammation,
interactions with the tumor stroma, and of course, driving tumor
growth. And the first data go back a little bit more than 10 years ago by
Paul Frenette, who was the first in mouse models to actually
cut the nerve to prostate cancer and actually has seen that
actually by cutting the nerve, the tumor cells actually
decrease growth, and there was this decreased metastasis.
And by now, many others actually have followedAnd in
principle, the sympathetic nervous system, adrenergic, motor, and
sensory interactions are typically tumor-promoting, and parasympathetic
ones are often inhibiting. But actually, there are
exceptions, which we probably will hear later.
So this generates now actually this new field of cancer neuroscience,
which was initiated really by my old friend Paul
Frenette and others, and is now driven from the central
glioblastoma part from Frank Winkler and Michel Monje, Frank being
actually also on my floor. And this is
also in memory of my old friend Paul Frenette, who passed
away much too early, and we were both working on leukemic stem
cells, and he said, "Andreas, the real thing you have to do is actually work on
cancer neuroscience." And this is now something which I, in fact,
do.
So if you look at the tumors, what you see is there is a
lot of innervation, but what actually, in fact, you see in the tumor
or in normal organs are the nerve endings.
And these nerve endings are connected to an axon
and connected at the end to the cell bodies.
But where are the cell bodies? The cell bodies are actually not in the organs.
They are not in the cancer, but they're in the peripheral ganglia.
And so cell bodies of cancer or normal innervating neurons are
located in peripheral ganglia, and for the PDAC, for pancreatic
cancer, this is the celiac ganglion, CG, next to aorta,
or the dorsal root ganglia, the sensory ones along the spinal
cords. So knowing that, it is clear that
the large data sets, TCGA, ICGC, 10X genomic
studies, where you take tumor pieces and submit it to multi-omics,
whatever,
sequencing, actually, they all lack the
information of the neurons because whatever you submit actually does
not contain the peripheral ganglia where the cell bodies of the
neurons are located.
Now, pancreatic cancer, as you all know, is still a dismal disease.
The five-year survival is in the range of about 10% to 12%.
It's typically a RAS, mostly KRAS-driven tumor,
and KRAS is during tumor progression.
It's activated, it's duplicated, it's whole genome amplified, so
RAS goes up.
So the standard therapy is FOLFIRINOX, combination
chemotherapy on paclitaxel and gemcitabine,
in addition to surgical
resection, which only 20% actually can profit from this.
So all recent trials failed, but there is great hope
with the new RAS inhibitors, and there are several talks also here at AACR from
companies such as Revolution Medicines.
They have really fantastic data, actually, that RAS
might actually be the way to target pancreatic cancer
in the future. So pancreatic cancer is characterized by a
very high desmoplastic stroma, meaning that
the epithelial cells can actually be only a minor component of the
cancer, and stroma can make up to 90%
of the tumor mass, which is quite amazing and actually generates obviously some
issues.
On top, by staining for neurofilament markers, in
particular pathologists, but also surgeons actually realized that
PDAC actually has hypertrophic nerves.
But this is all in 2D, so how does that look like when we now look
into an iDISCO and actually stain for the
peripheral nerves actually in
this human
PDAC cancer, which has been grown
endogenously by transplanting organoids onto
endogenous mouse pancreas. And you see actually this very
dense network. This is not blood vessels.
This is really peripheral nerves which innervate the
pancreatic cancer. But all those what you see are nerve
endings, and actually none of the cell bodies of these are
present within the tumor. And so what we then figured,
well, we need to develop technology to identify and
characterize the neurons at the transcriptional level.
And so for that, Vera and Simon actually developed Trace and Seek,
which identifies the transcriptomes or the proteomes of individual
pancreas versus PDAC innervating neurons.
And what they found is, or what they use is a tracer
called Fast Blue, which turned out to be the best one.
It's Fast Blue, which is injected into the pancreas or into the
pancreatic cancer in mouse models.
And actually, this Fast Blue is retrogradely transported back into the
ganglia and actually stains exactly those
neurons, which actually traject into the pancreas or into the pancreatic
cancer. This can be isolated and looked at
by fluorescence microscopy, but even more important, they
can be isolated individual neurons.
They can be sorted by Fast Blue and then sorted by
a flow cytometer individually into each well.
And from each well, you can then do downstream analysis, such as transcriptomic
analysis, or we have also done now proteomic analysis.
The technical details we have just now written together for nature protocols
because this can be used for any neuron, for any situation, any
mouse model, doesn't have to be cancer, can be heart attack or any other things.
So it's actually widely applicable.
So workflow consists of four key stages: the Fast Blue
tracer injection, then the ganglion dissociation and enzymatic
digestion, the neuronal enrichment, and single-cell
FACS sorting into 384-well plates.
And then you can do actually with these individual cells, any kind of multi-omics
analysis you actually want to do. So these show us the Fast Blue
injections. You get completely blue pancreas.
There is actually no spilling over typically, and you can actually
see that for the celiac ganglion, after 5 days, 7 days, 10
days, actually, it reaches actually the maximum at around 10 days, where the
tracing actually reaches from the pancreas to the celiac
ganglion. It takes a little bit longer for the dorsal root ganglion because they're
also farther away.Now, this is how it looks like with
this iDISCO. You have the pancreas, the spleen, and you have the celiac ganglion,
the dorsal root ganglion over here, and this is how it looks through a microscope.
And this is the celiac ganglion, which you have to dissect, and if you do trace and
seq, you see that many of the cells have actually double labeling with
a normal neuronal marker, but some actually don't.
So you need specifically actually this trace and seq technology to
separate neurons which go into your target organ and
neurons which actually don't go into your organ.
And then you do flow cytometry, you digest the
ganglia, you use a live cell death, you use NeuO to
separate or to specifically
enrich for neurons, and then you use Fast Blue, and then these cells
are then sorted into the 384 well plates and up
for
next analysis. And for the transcriptome, this is actually what you
get. You get this complete heterogeneity of the neurons you find in
the celiac ganglion, sympathetic ones as well as sensory
ones. And you see actually the different subtypes you get within
each of the ganglia. And on top of that, next to the identity of these
neurons, you also get differentially expressed genes.
And now we can actually fill in the missing
piece by the genes which are expressed in the
pancreas or in the PDAC, differentially in the celiac ganglion one or the
pancreas or PDAC in the dorsal root ganglion.
And we see a number of neuropeptides, neuroguidance molecules,
DNA repair, signaling molecules, structural proteins,
microtubule formation, and many others.
So what is the real difference between normal pancreas and PDAC?
And this is actually visible over here.
So what you see is this massively increased sprouting
in the pancreatic cancer. And this actually reminds us to
these two trees. There's only one stem.
Actually, the number of neurons is identical.
There's no proliferation going on in the ganglia.
So the number of neurons which traject into the normal or into
the cancerous
pancreas is actually the same. What you see is this massive sprouting,
which actually increases the contacts between neuronal nerve
endings and the pancreatic cancer cells.
And this is actually shown over here again,
in red, you see the image, and in yellow, you see actually
machine learning enhanced image analysis.
And you see actually this incredibly dense network of neurons
within the pancreatic cancer.
Now we, of course, validated this, and one of the genes we are very interested
in is Lin28b. I'm a stem cell person.
Lin28b is a classical stem cell gene, which is
probably involved in reactivation of embryonic program in these
terminally differentiated neurons, which probably increase neuronal
plasticity, axonal regeneration, and synaptic
reorganization. And we see also Robo slit signaling.
It's classic for axon pathfinding, probably navigating of the
neurons actually through the stroma, increased branching, and
synaptic remodeling. Something we also saw that
actually when we do this iDISCO and follow some of the nerves, that we see some
going through the pancreatic cancer actually into the spleen.
And so what Vera did is then actually do a double labeling, and indeed
she finds that in the ganglia, then there are individual
neurons which actually
target both the pancreatic cancer or the normal pancreas as well as
the spleen, which is quite amazing.
And so we did then also double labeling of the liver and the
pancreas, and actually you see that most of the neurons are
individual to one of the organs, but you see also some which
actually are targeting both, which means that PDAC reprogrammed
neurons may also innervate the liver.
They reprogrammed the liver, meaning that they might actually generate a
pre-metastatic niche, and we know that pancreatic cancer actually very
quickly and very effectively metastasizes to the
liver. Maybe also the nervous system is involved in facilitating
the growth of these cells in the liver.
To summarize,
we found that the neurons not only target and are
in contact with the cancer cells, but they're also in
direct contact with CAF cells, probably with vessels, and actually
potentially also close to immune cells.
Now, how important is this innervation?
And can we actually block it? And do we have maybe already drugs which are
already doing this to some degree?
And so for that, we used 6-OHDA, which is a drug which is
neurotoxic to adrenergic
neurons, that's been used by many others.
And if you do that and look at iDISCO, you actually only have the sensory
ones left, but the sympathetic ones are gone.
And if you do then growth assays in the PDX or in the
KPC model, actually the loss of the neurons actually very much
slow down the growth of these tumors.
And then we wondered, well, how about now paclitaxel?
Is that actually doing already something?
Because we all know in the clinic that paclitaxel actually
generates very severe neuropathy, so affecting the peripheral
nervous system.
And it's a microtubule stabilizer and thought to block mitosis, but maybe
it actually also blocks these peripheral nerves.
In support of that, there's a phase three clinical trial
published where there is a linking neuropathy to
PDAC outcome, and the patients who have very strong side
effects actually had a much longer overall survival.
Which doesn't prove anything, but actually suggests indeed that Abraxane may
affect infiltrating neural function and thus may be inhibiting
already some of the neurons in the cancer.
And this we can actually also see in neoadjuvant setting
whereWith a nab-paclitaxel treatment,
these neurons actually are decreased.
When we do trace and seq, what we see is that, indeed, the
sensory neurons actually go down to zero in response to
nab-paclitaxel and again, iDISCO, you see this untreated
nab-paclitaxel. You have the sympathetic ones left,
6-HDA, you have the sensories left.
It was not rocket science to actually combine the two.
And if you do, then the growth assays in the mice, actually we see that there's a
massive, really synergistic effect by actually blocking the
entire nervous system, sensory and sympathetic.
Actually, the tumors were barely growing at all.
Now, also something fitting to the topic of the session here.
We have denervation indeed turns immunosuppressive
CAFs, cancer-associated fibroblasts, into pro-inflammatory
CAFs. We see the proliferation is down, inflammation, T immune
signatures are up. The lymphocytes start to actually migrate again
into the pancreas. And by doing PD-1 inhibition in vivo,
we see that this actually can be resensitized.
So this may indicate that denervation may turn
immunological cold pancreatic cancer into a checkpoint inhibitor
responsive hot tumor. And there are also other data from Susan Kegg on beta
blockers, which actually suggest that this indeed could be the case on top of the
data we have generated. So then we decided, okay, so
let's take all what we found and translate this into an
early clinical trial, which we call synergy.
It's a phase one, phase two multi-center trial, and we thought we have to
do three things. First, to target the sympathetic
neurons in the celiac plexus. This is actually shown here.
This is a very busy area of the body, which also makes
pancreatic cancer surgery so tricky.
You can localize them by MRI or by actually PSMA
PET to actually localize them, which allows maybe in the
future for theranostic approaches.
We then target the sensory neurons by nab-paclitaxel gemcitabine, which
is anyway frontline or first-line treatment for pancreatic cancer.
And we would add a checkpoint blockade, a PD-1 inhibitor after
denervation. And so what we do now is actually we have to decide
it, and maybe here, this is actually done as a proof of
concept for the role of PNS. We thought actually to be able to
block almost entirely the celiac plexus to see
whether the microenvironment has actually a strong effect indeed,
to pancreatic cancer. And what we use is actually a radiotherapy-mediated
blockade of the celiac ganglion,
using 25 gray. And this is a linear accelerator,
which
is coupled to a MRI, which is called MR-linac, which allow us
to actually very specifically, only specifically, put the
radiotherapy on the area of the celiac ganglion.
And this approach has been used by others in the past.
Not for therapy, but actually for reducing of pain,
in patients who are terminally ill, and have a
lot of pain, and this was very successful.
And therefore, we thought that we can use this now and this approach,
to combine with gemcitabine nab-paclitaxel and two arms of
the PD-1 inhibitor. So the patients we will
include are locally advanced pancreatic cancer patients.
They are just not resectable anymore.
They are hyper-innervated by neurons, and they have
immune suppressive microenvironment.
And the goals would be to test whether indeed the 25 gray
actually indeed lead to a denervation together with the taxane.
The primary endpoint is progression-free survival, and another endpoint
we are quite excited about is secondary resectability.
So the goal is to reduce the size of this tumor again
to a moderate size, so that surgeons may be able to take
out the tumor again surgically. And of course, response rate and
immune response. So this is a phase one, phase two trial,
which we run not only in Heidelberg, but actually it's a two-arm multicenter
trial with six German comprehensive cancer centers.
We're currently trying to obtain the finances for that and actually
hope to start next year with this first cancer
neuroscience trial on pancreatic cancer. So what comes next?
Of course, the pancreatic cancer is not the only one
which has an involvement of neurons.
And we actually look at all of them. We analyze all of them and run trace and seq.
We have done this already, so map the sensory innervation of healthy organs
versus tumors. Here you see actually the data from the
dorsal root ganglia. We have now identified 15,000 cells
by flow cytometry and comparing healthy tissue,
primary cancers as well as metastasis.
And we are currently analyzing
those data, in greater detail, which is actually
quite difficult. And so we try to generate a
neuro-pan-cancer atlas. We also will include now
the nerves within the carcinoma ecosystem, which
includes the CAFs, the vessels, immune cells, as well as the tumor cells
to generate connectomes, to establish cancer nerve signals,
signatures, which should establish common but also
tumor entity-specific targets. We look
at synapses. This has been identified now by our colleagues in Munich,
Ekendemia, for synapses between
sensory nerves and
pancreatic cancer, but there might also be one with CAFs, is the
electrochemical stimulation, and actually turn more of these data into
early clinical trials. And with this,
I thank you for your attention and actually take
the credit. So credit is Vera Thiel, Simon Renders, who also will run,
actually, this clinical trial synergy. Jasper Panten.
We are in close collaboration with Frank Winkler, who is on our floor and our
expert in neurology. This is done in my lab
together with Martin Sprick. And this is all done at
Heistem within the German Cancer Research Center.
And this is Heistem. There are seven groups,
two interested in stem cells, but also cancer neuroscience.
And I'm just showing you while actually you prepare for questions, some
more videos of organs and stained for
the peripheral nervous system. Thank you very much and happy to take
questions.
Hi, Dani Engel from Salk Institute. Absolutely beautiful talk.
So I was wondering, since the nerves can actually innervate both the pancreas and
the liver, and there's such a high incidence of perineural invasion, have you
actually mapped these nerves as paths of metastasis to that
organ?
Not yet. There's two things. What we have mostly looked at is actually
the innervation within the pancreatic cancer.
There's also perineural invasion, which is actually the opposite.
So it's the nerve sheaths are innervated by
disseminating tumor cells, which then integrate or basically
migrate into the nerve sheaths, and that actually generates this
massive pain in later stage
cancers. And the cells actually also use the nerves as
a freeway to actually move towards the liver.
So this is a little bit of a different mechanism, but we are also looking at
that.
Hi, thanks for that. John White, UCSD.
So the pancreas is also innervated by enteric nerves as well.
When you did the tracing,
of course you're looking at the-
These we cannot look at.
Those-
You can't trace back-
No
... using the same mechanism for-
No, because they are basically inside the pancreas, right?
So there are some cell bodies. That's what you're talking about, or?
They go to the
gut, yeah.
Ah.
Yeah.
So not going to the ganglia, but actually
the innervation coming from the enteric nerves from the gut that are reaching the
pancreas.
Yeah, so in principle they can also be traced, but obviously you need to know
actually where the cell bodies are to actually exactly localize them and then
isolate-
For the install or take, yeah
... isolate the areas.
So I think that's also relevant for translational
science as well, because if you're looking at which nerves, of course, I'm sure
you see that they are tracing, so a good portion I'm sure are
going to these ganglia. But if you're looking to intervene and treat,
then if there's a contribution from the enteric nervous system,
maybe that's an access that you'd want to look at as well.
Yeah, absolutely. Very good point.
But it's amazing work. Thank you so much.
Yes, thank you.
Looking forward.
Hi. We've been treating
cancer for a long time. When you treat the
cancer with the chemotherapy,
what do you think is happening at the tumor neural interface, the
tumor cell neural interface, if this input
is coming and innervating them through
the mediators, cholinergic or muscarinic mediators released
into the TME?
Is it getting more stronger, you think, like to make the
tumor cells survive the chemotherapy?
Yes, probably. There are many different factors which we are trying to
figure out because there are clearly signaling pathways which link
to the CAFs, which link also to the
tumor cells. Definitely, there are more signals which actually drive
tumor genesis as well as actually provide survival signals from
the nerve to the tumor cells.
Okay. And the second question is, these immune
cells, they are moving, they are not fixed like CAFs.
So,
say it is like target on the go
and the neural modulation of these
T cells and the B cells the previous speaker spoke also,
how is it able to regulate
that input into those motile cells?
And also one more thing is the tumor excluded
immune cells, tumor included immune cells we talk about.
Right. That's what I was showing in passing a little bit, sort of
the nerve structures when the CAFs may actually
lead to this immunosuppressive microenvironment, because when you
block the nerves out again actually, then you change the CAFs in a
way so that the immune cells actually can be able to migrate in
again. That's something what we see, what we don't understand what the
details are, and which we are currently looking at. Thank you.
Thank you for the beautiful talk. You've dealt a lot in the immune
cells, how the innervation affects the immune cells that are
infiltrated in the tumor mass. Have you thought about how
those innervation affect the tumor cells, how they interact with one
another? And-
How the tumor cells interact with other tumor cells?
Or-
With nerve cells
With immune cells. With the?
Nerve cells that are innervated.
Oh, the nerve cells, yes. Well, there is now first
evidence that synapse-like structures indeed
actually are occurring next to trophic signals and specific
cytokines which actually may be released.
There might be also
some atypical synapse formation, which
is quite exciting. It has been shown in the central nervous system by
Michel Monje and Frank Winkler.
Right.
But now there is more and more data that there are also synapses in the
periphery, which actually add. So maybe the
cells are actually fired, literally fired up
by the nervous system.
Yeah. My related question is, do you think that has to do with anything with
neuroendocrine transformation that are often seen in pancreas?
Cannot exclude it. The typical neuroendocrine is in
lung cancer, in prostate cancer, and sometimes also in breast
cancer.
The neuroendocrine one is typically a different type of cancer.
It's not a PDAC.
I see. All right. Thank you.
Real quick question.
You're measuring the mRNA at the cell body level, but it's going to be
different at the end of these neurons.
Do you know anything about the different distribution of mRNA
there than in the cell body?
Very, very good question.
In the neurons, there is also a transport of RNAs actually to the nerve endings,
and there are ribosomes also at the nerve endings, which are producing.
So we are currently actually collaborating with people at EMBL to actually look at
that as well.
So I think that's an important part which we are indeed
partly missing by doing trace and seek.
All right. Thank you very much.
The last speaker
is Sebastien Talbot.
Okay.
Well, first of all, thank you, Professor Mack, for the invitation.
I'm super excited to be here today.
So my lab study neuroimmunology, we do that in various
contexts, including in allergy and asthma, as well as in
cancer.
And of course, today we're going to focus on cancer.
So I'd like to start the talk by giving you a little bit of
historical perspective that kind of underpin the field of cancer
neuroscience. So here is data that actually led
to Rita Levi-Montalcini 1986 Nobel
Prize, where she cultured chick
embryos, so sensory ganglia from chick embryo, in absence or
in presence of sarcoma. And you can see that when it's in the presence of sarcoma,
you see
those
neuron that actually start growing or projecting these axon.
Eventually, what she found is that those cancerous sarcoma was
secreting the nerve growth factor, and this was actually deriving
this very strong production of nerve.
So I think this is really underpinning the idea that cancer cell can
really attract these nerve,
to eventually
infiltrate tumor.
This is another picture from J.X. Mead in 1897 that actually
showed,
again in sarcoma, the presence of nerve.
So we know for a very long time that there is nerve inside of
cancer. We did not really know what were these nerve doing
until the emergence of the field of cancer neuroscience as it was
presented before by the two other speaker.
But it has been postulated that the nerve may be able to directly interact with
cancer cell and drive tumor growth.
Perhaps they interact with blood vessel and control angiogenesis,
or perhaps they actually interact with immune cells and control the function of the
immune cells against the tumor.
So my lab focus on sensory neuron, which we call also
nociceptor neuron. Nociceptor are actually a subtype of neuron
specialized in detecting danger.
Classically, they will detect, let's say, noxious heat.
They do that by expressing specific ion channel receptor.
When these ion channel receptor are activated, you will have an influx of different
ions, generation of action potential that travel from the periphery
all the way to the brain.
But something that's perhaps a little less appreciated is when these action
potential travel actually from the periphery all the way to the
cell body. When they reach axonal branch point, those axon
potential can actually travel back to the periphery, where they will lead
to the local release of neuropeptide.
Neuropeptide is the thing that they use to communicate with other neuron
or other cells in the tissue. Classic neuropeptide are
substance P and CGRP. So what happened is locally, this substance P and
CGRP will act on capillaries. They will increase blood flow,
increase vasodilation. They can increase the chemotaxis
and adhesion of immune cells, and eventually they will loosen the tight junction of
these blood vessel, and this will allow the immune cells actually to get out
of the capillaries and come in the microenvironment.
And the consequences of this is it will put in very close vicinity
immune cells and sensory neurons.
So this allow for this local crosstalk between the nerve and immune
cells. So this local crosstalk has been shown to be super important,
control immune responses at various barrier site.
Classic barrier site are, for example, the skin.
A lot of work has been done by the lab of Isaac Chiu in
the context of bacterial infection.
There's also interaction in the lung.
A lot of data has been done in the context of asthma, including from my
lab and also at the gut, again during
bacterial infection.
So neuroimmune interaction are important to regulate immune
function. For example, during, as I mentioned, bacterial infection
or viral infection or wound healing.
But what happen in the context of cancer?
So we decided to study this because it was not really known.
So we chose melanoma as our working model.
Why we chose melanoma? Because it's a great model of immunosurveillance, and we
know that the skin is densely innervated by sensory neurons.
We are also not expert in cancer, so we thought this would be easy enough to
actually measure tumor growth. You can just use a caliper and looked at the growth
on the skin.
So what we normally do is classic model, for example, B16-F10, that we
inject orthotopically in nociceptor intact in ablated mice,
meaning that we have mice in which we can specifically eliminate
subtype of neuron. Then we typically look at the presence of
itch or pain, which are marker of sensory neuron activation.
Eventually, we looked at the presence of nerve that will infiltrate the tumor.
At endpoint, we harvest the tumor, and we immunophenotype those tumor, and we
looked at immunity.
So here is one of the first experiment that we did, is we give melanoma to our
nociceptor intact and ablated mice.
To eliminate nociceptor, in this case, we use a TRPV1 cre diphtheria toxin.
So this mice actually, as I mentioned, will actually kill
specifically pain transmitting neuron and mainly the neuron that produce
neuropeptides.
So what we found is that in absence of sensory neuron, we have smaller tumor
growth, and we have longer survival.
And when we immunophenotype those tumor, we found that there were more CD8 T cell
per milligram of tumor. But most interestingly, we found that there were higher
interferon gamma positive CD8 T cell, and it seems that those T cell were
less exhausted. So lower level of PD-1, LAG-3, and TIM-3 positive
CD8 T cells.
So this suggests that perhaps the neuron control immune
function. But we ask ourselves, can the cancer cell also
impact the function of neuron? So to study this, we decided to use a
co-culture approach in which we co-culture DRG neuron in the
presence or absence of melanoma.We did that for 48
hours, and then we FACS purified each cell type and RNA-Seq them.
And we found that when the neuron were co-culture with the cancer cell, they
drastically overexpressed many different neuropeptide, including
Calcitonin which encode for CGRP, so this classic neuropeptide.
So as I mentioned, neuropeptide are the mediator by which
neuron impact immunity. So we ask ourself, can this CGRP
would be able to impact T cell function?
So we looked at this in many different ways.
I'm going to show you one which is the simplest one.
We harvest basically naive splenocyte CD8 T cell, we
make them to be cytotoxic, and we expose them to CGRP.
And what we found is that CGRP seems, again, to drive the exhaustion of those T
cell, meaning they express higher level of PD-1, LAG-3, and TIM-3,
and lower level of interferon gamma.
This effect was actually absent when we harvested a
RAMP1 knockout CD8 T cell, RAMP1 being the receptor for
CGRP.
Not showing you all the data, but we eventually shows that if you put CGRP
on OT-1 CD8 T cell, they were less able to
eliminate B16-F10 ova. So we really think that CGRP is able to
drive exhaustion of the T cells.
But to confirm this in vivo, we decided to use a RAMP1 knockout mice.
RAMP1, as you may know, have no B and no T cells.
So what we did is we transplanted either a RAMP1 wild type or
RAMP1 knockout CD8 T cells, so T cells that do not respond to
CGRP. So in these mice, in which the T cell
cannot respond to CGRP, we found that there's smaller tumor growth.
In some of our mice, we co-transplanted both RAMP1 wild type and RAMP1
knockout CD8 T cell. And using CD45.1 and
CD45.2, we could track each subset of T
cell within the same tumor. And what we found, I think, is pretty
interesting. Again, lower exhaustion in our RAMP1
knockout CD8 T cells. So less PD-1, LAG-3, TIM-3 positive CD8 T
cell. But to really confirm that, we actually
FACS purify and then RNA-Seq those T cell.
And again, in the knockout CD8 T cell, there's lower expression of Tox,
Eomes, and other markers, suggesting again that there's perhaps lower
exhaustion of CD8 T cell.
So is this relevant for patients? So if you looked at
TCGA data, you see that high RAMP1
expression melanoma seems to be bad for the patient.
But most interestingly is when you looked at single-cell RNA-Seq
data. So Aviv Regev had two paper published from melanoma
patient. So because it's single cell, you can parse T cell in
different populations. So we parse them either expressing high level of RAMP1
or low level of RAMP1. So within melanoma patient,
if you express high level of RAMP1, the T cell, again, seems to be more exhausted.
So higher expression of PD-1, TIM-3, LAG-3, CTLA4.
Not showing you all the data. The paper has been published now for a few years.
But what we found is that melanoma is densely innervated by sensory neuron,
that melanoma activates
sensory neuron by the secretion of SLEEPY.
The sensory neuron will locally release CGRP.
It will act on RAMP1 positive CD8 T cell and drive their exhaustion.
And what we eventually found is that if you block the sensory neurons using
different drug, for example, QX314, or if you block the RAMP1
receptor using the IBN4096, you prevent or you reduce
T cell exhaustion, which are then able to fight better the tumor, so we have
smaller tumor growth.
Now I'm showing you some data that we looked at neuron signature.
As we all know, when we looked at TCGA data, we normally
looked at only one marker. So Ben HK, actually created
at University of Toronto, created that tool which he called
predictio.ca, which you can access. It's freely accessible.
It's pretty cool, where you can look at different expression of different marker.
So we wanted to look at a neuron signature, in this case, classic marker of
neuron, including Trpv1, Nav1.8, RAMP1, and we found that
our signature seems to be very bad for patient survival.
It seems to be even worse than T cell exclusion.
So having this neuron signature within cancer
excuse me, seems to be very bad for patient.
Then again, if we looked at the signature and whether a patient would respond
better or not to IO, we found that only for melanoma, again,
having this neuron signature seems to be a predictor for bad
responsiveness to immunotherapy.
So I'm going to show you data that's been generated or led by my colleague
Alex Birbrair at Wisconsin Medicine.
And he ask itself what happened with melanoma when they metastasize to the lung.
So all our data so far were in the primary site.
What happened in lung mets? So to do this, he used, again, B16-F10,
in which he injected intravenously to a nociceptor
neuron reporter mice. In this case, it's a Nav1.8 Cre TD
tomato.
And what he found in comparison to normal lung, the lung that were actually
bearing those metastasis, they were more innervated.
So there's perineural or perimetastatic innervation, but there's also
intrametastatic innervation. So there's presence of neuron in and
around those lung mets. So what would happen if you eliminate those
neurons? So if you use RTX, which is a drug to eliminate sensory
neuron, he said there were less metastasis.
So then he wanted to confirm that using genetic model.
In this case, he used chemogenetics.
To do this, he used a Nav1.8
Cre-HM4QDI,
in which you can specifically, in this case, block sensory neuron
via the injection of CNO. And he found that if you
inject CNO in those mice, you're actually
decreasing, again,
lung metastasis.
So what is happening in those lung met?
What is the crosstalk between the nerve and the lung mets?
So first of all, if you looked at TCGA data in
patient that have lung metastasis, you can compare a live patient and
patient that eventually pass. In patient that pass, he saw that there were
higher expression of RAMP1. And then again, if you looked
at survival data, it seems that in patient that
express high level of RAMP1, they seems to survive less.But what was
super interesting is when you actually compare primary
melanoma to a melanoma that actually metastasized
to the lung. So if you harvest these guys and
profile them using qPCR, we see that the melanoma that actually met to
the lung drastically
overexpressed RAMP1. This is about 10 or 20-fold higher
expression of RAMP1.
So then he ask itself, what happen if we remove RAMP1 expression of these cancer
cells? So he used CRISPR-Cas9 to knock out RAMP1 out
of YUM 1.7. And he sees that in absence of RAMP1
expression
on those cancer cell, there's also less lung metastasis.
Another thing that he discover is that RAMP1 is not specifically only
expressed on the cancer cell. They seem to be also expressed by
PDGFR beta positive cell. PDGFR beta is our marker
of pericytes.
And again, if you compare a normal lung to a lung that actually is
bearing lung mets, the pericyte drastically overexpress
RAMP1. Here it's 100-fold overexpression.
Another thing that he discover is that CGRP positive neuron are in
very close proximity to those pericytes,
suggesting that perhaps the neuron is able to control pericyte function.
So to look into this, he decided, well, he use the Cre-Lox toolbox to
actually flux out RAMP1 out of the pericyte.
And what he discover is that in absence of RAMP1 on those pericyte, there's
smaller tumor growth.
Then one of the question of one of our reviewer was, is this relevant for patient?
And
he asked us a very tough question where he wanted us to do a
clinical trial in metastatic melanoma in the lung, which
as you may think, this would be pretty complicated.
So we're trying to go around this question where
Alex was able to access about 100 million patient data
set. And he looked at whether those patient were actually having
melanoma or not. And he found about 40,000 patient that had melanoma,
and some of those patient were actually treated with RAMP1
antagonists. So now there's RAMP1 antagonists on the market, and they are
used to treat migraines, for example.
So the acceptance of this drug is pretty recent, but he was still able to find
about 120 patient. But the cool part was that those
patient that were actually treated with those RAMP1 antagonists
seems to actually be doing better than the control patient.
So of course, these data have a bit of caveat.
We don't know when the treatment was started.
We don't know when the indication of the treatment.
But nevertheless, it seems that using RAMP1
antagonists potentially is helping
patient with lung metastasis, or actually metastasis in general.
This is not only lung.
So again, not showing you all the data, but something really cool that he found is
that primary melanoma, when they met to the lung, they start overexpressing
RAMP1. They can then respond to CGRP produced by
these nociceptor neuron. He found that this will drive tumor
growth. He also found that pericyte will also
overexpress RAMP1. They will receive signal from nociceptor neuron,
and that will drive proliferation and angiogenesis of the tumor.
So now I'm going to show you,
over the last five minute, another story that's now published.
Wanted to see how nociceptor neuron control tumor growth beyond
CGRP, and this is work that's been carried out in collaboration with Moran Amit at
MD Anderson.
So what we decided to do, and it's very similar to what Andreas actually showed
you, is how melanoma or whether melanoma are reprogram,
or whether how melanoma reprogram tumor innervating neurons.
So to do this, again, very similar to what Andreas did, we injected melanoma in
the INPA of the mice. Why the INPA? Is because we can
specifically trace these neuron to L3 to L5
DRGs, harvest those L3 to L5 DRGs,
purify nociceptor neuron using tdTomato, and then single-cell RNA seq
them. And one of the thing that we found is that, well, there was a unique
population of neuron in a melanoma-bearing animal,
and there's
a lot of differentially expressed genes across different subset of neuron.
But really, this unique population of neuron were actually expressing
ATF3. ATF3 is a key transcription
factor that's expressed specifically in injured neurons.
So this is very classic. If you have nerve injury,
ATF3 is absolutely essential to allow neuron to actually
regrow in the nerve stump. So finding this ATF3
in our tumor innervating neuron was very cool, so wanted to follow up on
this.
So first of all, we use a ATF3 reporter animal to confirm that,
yes, tumor innervating neuron were actually expressing
ATF3. But most interestingly, we wanted to see what happen if you
flux out ATF3 from nociceptor neurons.
If we make them resistant to injury, what happen?
So we found that there were smaller tumor growth and smaller tumor weight.
And then we ask ourself, how is this actually happening?
So we decided to profile immune cells inside of
those tumor, and we found that in our
injury-resistant mice, we found there was higher expression of, or
higher infiltration of interferon gamma positive CD8 T cell.
And we also did single-cell RNA seq of this tumor.
And what we found is that there's lower level of LAG3 expression of T
cell, but also that tumor-associated macrophages,
their potential to be immunosuppressive seems
to be less, meaning they express lower level of IL1B,
CD86, and CD80.
Because of time, I'm going to just skip this one.
But why is this actually interesting is because Moran had a
population of patient,
a cutaneous squamous cell carcinoma patient that were treated or not with
anti-PD-1.And he had sample before,
during, and after treatment. And of course, the patient might respond or
not to the treatment. But the really cool part is that in non-responding
patient, he found that there's a lot of perineural invasion.
Perineural invasion, as it was discussed by Andreas, is basically,
the tumor will kind of engulf the nerve,
and that will lead to
actually potentially injury to the nerve.
And really this is what we actually found.
We characterize those perineural invasion, and we're able to
find that in the non-responder, they seem to overexpress
ATF3. So both in our mice, but also in our patient that do not
respond to treatment, ATF3 seems to
overexpress in these
neuron that have perineural invasion.
So then we decided to create a signature for these injured
neuron, and we wanted to see, well, is this nerve injury
signature correlate with poor or bad prognosis for patient?
And across different cancer type, including our
cutaneous squamous cell carcinoma, PD-1
treated melanoma patient, gastric cancer treated with PD-1, as well as
another cohort of melanoma patient treated with PD-1.
In every cases,
nerve injury seems to be correlated with poor prognosis for the patient.
So based on this, we went back to our cutaneous squamous cell carcinoma patient,
and we decided to do Visium transcriptomic on these slides.
So we had three different gene profile.
One that's nerve injury in green, one that's immunosuppression
in red, and one that's good, so meaning good anti-tumor
immunity in purple. And we find a very great overlap
between nerve injury and immunosuppression.
And when there's no nerve injury, we found really good presence of
anti-tumor immunity. Meaning that, again, it seems that this nerve injury seems to
be very bad for anti-tumor immunity.
Again, not showing you all the data due to time, but what we found is that
during tumor growth, including melanoma, the nerve become injured.
They overexpress ATF3, this injury marker.
Downstream of this, the nerve will overexpress galanin.
We found that galanin actually drive T cell exhaustion, but we also
found that the nerve overexpress interferon-1 and IL-6,
which then will act on tumor-associated macrophages.
So another cool part, the paper was published last year, but what was really cool
to see
that in the same issue, a different group completely found that also nerve
injury was present and seems to be bad for glioblastoma
progression. So it seemed that this nerve injury signature, it's
pretty constant across tumor type and also perhaps in
glioblastoma.
So I think I'm out of time here.
Just concluding,
yeah, I'm just going to stop here, actually.
All right. Thank you, guys. I'm going to thank the people that did the work in my
lab.
Mohamed, Mariam, and Tuani, our collaborator, Alex
in Madison, Wisconsin, Moran at MD Anderson, Payver Mir
in SUFA, Ronit Rapkin at UPenn, Nicole
Schiff at Pitt, Vijay Kuchroo at HMS,
Karen Dixon in Basel, and our student, Elisa Pretto.
So on this, I'm going to welcome any questions.
Sorry to went over a little bit longer.
Really interesting talk.
Is it true of the liver also, and is it the same mechanism,
Ramp1 CGRP?
It's a great question. Liver is a bit of a weird organ, actually.
We don't see too much sensory neuron innervation in
the liver. If you do, actually,
I disco, at least I did some of that during my post-doc.
I did not see too much sensory neuron innervation in the liver.
That said, there's other cells that produce CGRP, so
potentially that CGRP Ramp1 could also be present in liver
cancer or liver in general.
Second question was about Nav1.8
and whether it's another kind of neuron,
and
does it overlap with the Ramp1 axis?
Yeah. So sorry. So Nav1.8 is a classic marker of nociceptor
neuron. It labels about 80% of them.
And within those Nav1.8 neuron, about
25% are CGRP positive, so the one that would act on
Ramp1. So the one that would act on Ramp1 is a smaller subset of
the Nav1.8.
Thank you.
Yes.
I wanted to write that down. Sorry about that.
I hate to open the can of worms of T cell exhaustion-
Yep
... but I was curious about your CGRP co-culture and how you
defined CD8 T cell exhaustion, if you had a subset or
a gene set.
Yeah. In our case, we looked at PD-1, Tim-3, like 3
positive, interferon gamma negative, but, I guess, as you
said it's a bit of a chemo war. One of the
experiment that
I liked,
I think was the best one to show that it was a B16F10
ova OT1 CD8 T cell co-culture plus minus CGRP,
and then that was actually decreasing by 50% the elimination of the
cancer cell. So whether it's true exhaustion.
So the way we rolled that is effect immuno surveillance,
so it's kind of a little bit broader than, I guess, true
or absolute exhaustion.
Yeah. Quick mechanistic question.
ATF3 can be activated through different pathways.
Do you have an idea which pathway is responsible in this case?
That's a great question. This is something we haven't really looked into.
Yeah, I think that's really open to be tested.
Yes. Thank you.
Sorry.
Yep, go for it.
Talk about this
tumor cells pumping various autoantibody exosomes.
Yep.
And in this case, the neural
tumor cells can also
exosomes.
Yeah.
And did anybody look at them? What are those,
are those exact exosomes between the
two-way transfer?
Yeah, so
Payver Mir actually had a Nature Comm paper where she showed that
head and neck tumor were innervated
because they were secreting exosome,
and that was actually driving the innervation.
And Moran had a 2021
Nature paper looking at exosome as well in head and neck, but he looked at a
subset.
It was a microRNA, which I don't remember right now which one
it is, but if you look him up, he did look at a specific microRNA.
That I'm sorry.
Okay, thank you.
So I just want to thank the speakers